[Musique]
ça va commencer
à
[Rires]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas possible
oh
un défi flotte
juillet quelque 4,4
hop
un gardien
au choix
m
pour
aulas
le rédige le pouce non
non
change
oh
et
audi norrath un truc taf est formidable
majeur op
on ya comme un top
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il
[Musique]
monde
où
[Musique]
m
où
[Musique]
m
le mapaq
bon
m
et
[Musique]
les
ok
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
oh
bah
à
mais
[Musique]
à
crois tu fais un bisou et girard ces
trucs maintenant j'ai besoin bouton pour
faire ce truc des boutons donne walden
mois de deux boutons canal 3 ou 4 tu
veux pas anigo estime en doutaient aussi
j'en ai apporté voilà et maternelle oui
absolument plein rien versé bouton on va
en garder
voilà on va écouter quatre ça suffira
pour moi alors regarde bien on prend ces
boutons mais là je les mets dans ma main
c'est ça je retiens kurt je fais un
petit geste combien crois tu qu'il en
reste 24 noms de ont disparu je rends
plus que deux protons toi ça eh ben je
voulais ce pic en vérité deux boutons
sont collés et vous vous seulement des
boutons vous en acheter plusieurs vous
encore les deux sur une carte normale et
on obtient ceci c'est le truc
oui alors la rajoute deux boutons qu'on
peut bouger
une seule est ce qu'il ne faut pas
oublier ces deux en tournant la main
voyez vous c'est comme ceux ci de faire
attention à ce que les deux boutons mais
de bien tourner la carte pour que vos
amis ne voit pas parce qu'on est comme
ceux ci et de courbes et la carte un
petit peu de façon à la pause et sans
que les boutons gêne et ont varié
m'entraîner deux zones d'accord tir il
est ce que tu veux essayer de le faire
allez fais le pour alberto j aimerais tu
me fais un week end
met toi bien comme ça qu alberto voit
bien regardez bien regarde de 3,4
oui 2 il a réussi quand il fait ça
magicien l'audit
[Musique]
e
où
et
bon
[Musique]
à
oh
à roques
oui je feins tu as faim au léger à ses
fins et pensait pensais pas je ferai le
panier le petit casque et un petit
fauteuil la nappe attendons à bas prix
les prix les gains et maintenant
comme ça
[Musique]
petit coup de vieux oublier les
brochettes les manchettes mais non les
poussettes sont la réponse est oui si
pour du gros gibier
on fait ce qu'on veut
ben si c'est comme ça
tant pis pour vous tu as subi c'est toi
qui est sonné car tu as années à faire
tourner sept fois sa dette
[Musique]
regarde toi
c'est
tu as rien y'a rien attends attends
si jamais il ya chez revend tu vas voir
le serpent on sert pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
s'il ya un sherpa il pense à mes yeux
car dieu
[Musique]
c'est pas sauvé par en dessous non pas
regarder plus haut car des gars là les
morts dont certains faisaient c'était
son dernier sursaut metal and as tu
parles de figues relâché et alors
voilà
à temps non j'y tiens tant il sait que
si un serpent mais il
voilà je vais écrasé tu mouilles à
partir points au compteur c'est ce qu'a
fait remonter le moral ah oui voilà
comme ça
[Musique]
ils sont partis
e
j'étais à l'approché toi
[Musique]
[Rires]
l'ajustement ce revers de rang
et pourquoi pas
présents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]